>> Dagen: PRESIDENT BIDEN IS NOT
ON THE BALLOT BUT DEMOCRATS ARE
LETTING IT BE KNOWN HOW
EMBARRASSED THEY ARE.
44% OF PEOPLE IN HIS PARTY WANT
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN BIDEN TO BE
THE 2024 NOMINEE.
WHILE OVERSEAS, BIDEN TRYING TO
SPIN HIS LEADERSHIP AS A
SUCCESS.
>> IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
ECONOMY IS GROWING, UNITED
STATES IS GROWING.
THIS THANKSGIVING WE'RE IN A
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE.
THINGS ARE A HELL OF A LOT
BETTER AND THE WAGES HAVE GONE
UP HIGHER, FASTER THAN
INFLATION.
WE HAVE GENERATED REAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
ADD BAD AS THINGS ARE, HURTING
FAMILIES NOW, TRADE THIS
THANKSGIVING FOR LAST
THANKSGIVING.
>> Harold: HAROLD, WAGES ARE NOT
KEEPING UP WITH INFLATION.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON, FOX HAS THE
VOTER ANALYSIS THAT WE'LL SEE ON
THE SIDE OF THE SCREEN FROM THE
ELECTION TODAY.
KEEP AN EYE ON THAT.
PUT YOUR LISTENING EARS ON.
WAGES ARE NOT KEEPING UP WITH
INFLATION.
INFLATION IS RUNNING ACCORDING
TO ONE GAUGE AT THE FASTEST PACE
IN 30 YEARS, HAROLD.
>> VOTERS ARE AS CONCERNED AS I
AM ABOUT INFLATION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH VOTERS ARE
GIVING HIM OR ASSIGNING ALL THE
BLAME TO BIDEN OR THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
DEMOCRATS LOSE THEIR SENSE OF
HUMOR ABOUT THINGS.
THEY'RE VERY REACTIVE PEOPLE.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED RIGHT NOW
WITH THE FACT THAT HE CAN'T SEEM
TO REFEREE THE MODERATES AND
PROGRESSIVES.
IF WE SIT HERE TOMORROW AND THE
NEW JERSEY RACE GOES DEMOCRAT,
THE VIRGINIA RACE GOES DEMOCRAT,
ERIC ADAMS AS MAYOR OF NEW YORK
AND HE REALLY USHERS IN A PUBLIC
SAFETY PLATFORM, CHANGES THE
CONSTRUCT AND DIRECTION OF THE
CITY AND THEY PASS SOMETHING IN
THE HOUSE AND SENATE, THE
PROBLEM WILL PROBABLY GO BACK
UP.
I DON'T QUARREL WITH YOU.
AS YOU AND I BOTH KNOW, THEY S&P
AND THE DOW AND NASDAQ CLOSED AT
RECORDS.
AIM CAPITALIST DEMOCRAT.
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE COUNTRY
TO GROW AND IMPORTANT FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
WE OUGHT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR
BEING A PART OF THIS STORY.
>> Dagen: G.G.?
>> Harold: I LOVE THAT.
>> Greg: THAT WAS MY NICKNAME
WHEN I DANCED.
>> Jesse: THE SUPER SPREADER.
>> Greg: THAT WAS IN THE LOW
DAYS WHEN I HAD TO MAKE MONEY
THE HARD WAY.
I WAS JUST THINKING THAT
de BLASIO FILED TO RUN FOR
GOVERNOR FOR NEW YORK, RIGHT?
DIDN'T HE?
THAT IS SCARIER THAN ANY OF
THIS.
ANYWAY, THE 44% OF DEMOCRATS
WANT ANOTHER PERSON BESIDES
BIDEN.
YOU HAVE TO REMIND YOURSELF THE
NUMBER WAS PROBABLY HIGHER WHEN
HE WAS ACTUALLY RUNNING.
THEY SAID JUST GET IN AND WE'LL
FIGURE IT OUT LATER.
THIS IS ACTUALLY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, PART OF THE PLAN,
RIGHT?
THEY NEVER SAID WE LOVE JOE AND
WE'RE GOING TO STICK WITH THEM
TILL 2024.
THEY WANTED HIM IN THE DOOR AND
REPLACE HIM WHEN HE FALLS APART
WHICH COULD BE A YEAR OR LESS
THAN A YEAR.
THE PROBLEM IS THE BACKUP
QUARTERBACK SUCKS AND THEY NEED
A NEW ONE.
THEY EXPECTED TO GET A JOE
MONTANA INSTEAD, THEY GOT A TODD
MORANVICH?
>> Dagen: THAT'S EXCELLENT.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO HE IS.
>> Dagen: I DO.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER HIS DAD.
CRAZY.
>> Dagen: I HAVE NO WHERE TO GO
WITH THAT.
JESSE?
WE'RE GETTING INTO A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE MORANVICH
CLAN.
>> Jesse: I DON'T WANT TO ENGAGE
IN A SPORTS CONVERSATION WITH
GUTFELD.
THAT'S GOING NOWHERE.
THIS IS A POLL OF DEMOCRATS, SO
I HAVE TO PUT MY DEMOCRATIC
THINKING CAP ON.
I HAVE TO SLOUCH AND FROWN.
THE DEMOCRATS I KNOW BECAUSE I
KNOW DEMOCRATS, THEY WANT POWER.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
SO THIS POLL ACKNOWLEDGES IT.
THEY DON'T THINK THAT JOE BIDEN
CAN WIN RE-ELECTION.
THEY THINK HIS PRESIDENCY IS SO
FAR COSTING THEM POWER IN THE
HOUSE.
DEMOCRATS OBVIOUSLY WANT THEIR
AGENDA ENACTED AND SO FAR JOB
HAS NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BE INSPIRED.
THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS USUALLY
VOTE FOR THE GUY THAT SENDS THE
THRILL DOWN THEIR LEG.
YOU KNOW, BUBBA OR BARACK.
IS JOE BIDEN INSPIRING
DEMOCRATS?
NO.
HE CAN BARELY MAKE IT THROUGH A
SPEECH IN A TEMPORARY PROMPTER.
HE'S BORING AND THREATENING
THEIR HOLD ON POWER.
THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS ARE FLEEING
LIKE -- CAN I FACT CHECK HIM ONE
MORE TIME?
HE'S COMPARING THIS THANKSGIVING
TO LAST THANKSGIVING?
WE'RE AVERAGING MORE COVID-19
DEATHS TODAY THAN WE AVERAGED
LAST YEAR SAME TIME AND SAME
AMOUNT OF CASES.
SO THINGS ARE NOT GOTTEN BETTER
IN TERMS OF COVID WITH JOE BIDEN
ON THAT METRIC.
>> Jeanine: THE TRUTH IS THAT
JOE BIDEN IS LOSING ON
EDUCATION, HE'S LOSING ON THE
CORONAVIRUS, IN ADDITION TO
THAT, THE DEMOCRATS AS YOU SAY,
JESSE, ARE NOT INSPIRED.
THEN YOU HAVE A SCENARIO WHERE
THE GUY FALLS ASLEEP IN AN
INTERNATIONAL CONFERENCE AND
SHOWS UP AT A CLIMATE CONFERENCE
THAT WE'LL TALK ABOUT LATER WITH
85 CAR-MOTORCADE.
EVERYTHING IS INCONSISTENT WITH
HIS MESSAGE.
HE CAN'T KEEP HIS OWN PARTY
TOGETHER.
EVERYBODY IS DISAPPOINTED IN
HIM.
KAMALA HARRIS, THEY HAVE NO
WHERE TO GO WITH HER.
SO, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE LIKE --
THEY'RE TOTALLY FRUSTRATED WITH
THEIR OWN PARTY.
THE TRUST IS WHEN YOU HAVE
MANCHIN SAYING HE'S PLAYING
SHELL GAMES AND BUDGET GIMMICKS,
NOBODY IS BUYING ANYTHING THAT
HE'S SELLING.
NOTHING OF WHAT HE IS SELLING IS
POSITIVE OR ANYBODY WANTS TO
ENGAGE IN.
>> Dagen: THE ONLY WAY HE WAS
ELECTED IS TO NOT BE PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN STYLE, BUT NOT
SUBSTANCE.
JUST IN STYLE.
INSTEAD, HE COMES IN AND
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE, AGAIN, THE
REPUBLICANS LOST IN GEORGIA AND
IMMEDIATELY STARTED REFERRING TO
L.B.J. AND F.D.R.
THAT'S NOT WHAT PEOPLE ELECTED
HIM TO.
QUITE FRANKLY WOULD BE BETTER
OFF IF HE WAS ASLEEP ALL THE I'M
TOO.
>> Jeanine: BUT WHO IS RUNNING
THE COUNTRY?
>> Greg: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Jeanine: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT SCHOOLS?
>> Greg: THEY TAKE THEM OVER.
PULL THEIR KIDS
>> Jeanine: WHEN?
>> Greg: TOMORROW.
WE'RE ALL DOING IT TOGETHER.
I DON'T HAVE KIDS SO I'M N